So, ich muss noch mal ein Streaming Rechner anmachen, ich sehe noch keinen Chat oder irgendwas.
Solange er startet muss ich mal hier den Chat einblenden, dass ich den Chat nicht übersehe.
Ach guck mal, da blende ich den Chat hier aus, das ist was für ein Elf.
So, ich muss noch mal ein Streaming Rechner anmachen, dass ich den Chat in der Vorschau habe.
Habt ihr auch das Problem mit Windows 10, dass das sehr inkonsistent Anwendungen startet beim Neustart?
Also, die haben das jetzt ja so eingebaut, dass wenn man rebootet, dass danach die Anwendungen wieder,
oder teilweise die Anwendungen wieder gestartet werden, die vorher liefen und das ist bei mir ziemlich inkonsistent.
Das funktioniert man, mal funktioniert es nicht, mal funktioniert es nur zur Hälfte.
Ich weiß nicht so genau, was das für ein komisches Feature von Microsoft sein soll.
Achso, ich glaube jetzt läuft es.
Ja, funktioniert es.
Aber es funktioniert bei mir nicht richtig.
Ach, ich mein gut. Was funktioniert bei Windows 10 schon gut bedienbar und richtig?
Es läuft, das ist aber auch das einzige.
Im Vergleich zu früher kackt das nicht laufend ab, aber ansonsten ist Windows 10 jetzt nicht unbedingt das Highlight für mich.
Gut, die anderen Windows Versionen auch nicht.
Ich glaube, dass Windows mit dem ich bisher am längsten, also das Windows, was mir am wenigsten auf den Kicks gegangen ist,
das ist so halbe halbe.
Also ich würde sagen, an sich Windows XP oder Windows 7, aber Windows 10 hat auch seine Vorteile.
Aber Windows 10 ist halt so inkonsistent. Windows 10 ist halt so ein Sammelsurium aus tausend Sachen.
Ich meine allein schon, dass es sowas hier noch gibt und dass man beispielsweise hier Sachen aninstallen kann,
aber dass man auch hier Sachen aninstallen kann, was mehr oder weniger der gleiche Kram ist.
Nur manche Sachen stehen hier nicht drin, dafür stehen sie hier drinnen.
Und dass es dann auch solche Sachen wie das hier zum Beispiel gibt, was einfach mal hyper oldschool ist,
oder wenn man es noch älter haben will, geht man hier hin, da sieht man was für ein Sammelsurium Windows 10 mittlerweile ist.
Ist nicht ernsthaft oder? Schlafen muss sein.
Das ist total random. Und dann gibt es noch solche komischen Anwendungen, die noch mal anders aussehen.
Jetzt haben wir hier verschiedene Stufen von Windows Anwendungen, je nachdem wie alt sie sind nebeneinander.
Und ich weiß, es gibt noch viele noch ältere und sowas in der Richtung.
Ich meine, was ist mit Microsoft los?
Aber auf einen Schlag, das neue wäre Aufschrei gewesen.
Na ja, ich würde das erwarten eigentlich, dass man das mal ordentlich umstellt.
Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass wir es jemals erleben werden, dass diese Einstellungen hier verschwinden.
Dafür sind die neuen Menüs auch zu featurearm im Endeffekt. Du kannst ja viele Sachen gar nicht machen.
Ja, richtig, richtig. Man kann viele Sachen nicht machen.
Ich meine, man muss mal nur vergleichen. Ich mache mal zu.
Man muss mal nur vergleichen, die Display-Settings in dem hier mit den...
Fuck, wie kommt man überhaupt noch in die alten Display-Settings irgendwie rein?
Kommt man in die alten Display-Settings überhaupt noch rein?
Ich glaube, die alten Display-Settings sind sogar weg.
Und dann? Ah, das sind die alten Display-Settings, zumindest teilweise.
Man muss hier hin, wenn man die Wiederholfrequenz einstellen will.
Das ist eigentlich der Witz, ne?
Da muss ich mal überlegen. Ich will einfach sowas Publiches wie die Wiederholfrequenz von meinem Monitor einstellen.
Da muss ich in das alte Menü rein.
Microsofts excellent GUI-Design.
Warum gibt es hier nicht sowas wie bei jedem anderen Betriebssystem, was mir so einfällt in den Display-Settings?
Auflösung und darunter einfach Refresh Rate.
Warum muss ich für die Refresh Rate irgendwo da unten hin und dann...
Wo muss ich hin? Ich hab schon wieder vergessen. Dahin und... Nee.
Oh nee, ich hab...
Wie bin ich da jetzt hingekommen?
Wisst ihr mal, das ist total wirr.
Ich hab vergessen, wie ich hier hingekommen bin.
Advanced. Nee.
Ah.
Ha. Nee.
Sollte das jetzt nicht eigentlich aufgehen?
Achso, es geht im Hintergrund auf, wo wir wieder dabei sind, wie fällig das Ganze eigentlich ist.
Es ist halbinos, ne?
Auch das Color-Profil-Management ist sehr elementär, weil man da verschiedene Sachen hat.
Also, es ist einfach inkonsistent. Und ich spekuliere ja drauf, dass es eventuell besser werden könnte.
Das hab ich ja schon ein paar Mal gezeigt. Wenn sie es endlich schaffen, ihren Kram rauszubringen,
dass es auch auf dem Desktop läuft.
Also quasi, das ist das neue UI-Zeug, was die ganze Zeit,
wenn es im Kern nur für UWP verfügbar war, bloß halt noch ein bisschen besser,
noch ein bisschen mehr an den Desktop angepasst.
Und mit der neuen Version...
...kommt das für den Desktop.
Und das ist kein Electron, das ist wirklich native Windows GUI.
Der Grund, warum...
Ich muss mal kurz was trinken und husten.
Der Grund, warum Electron-Anwendungen überhaupt so beliebt sind,
liegt ja daran, dass Microsoft es nicht geschafft hat, 20 Jahre lang
eine einheitliche, ordentliches UI-Framework anzubieten,
was halt der definitive Weg ist, Windows-Anwendungen zu machen.
Unter Mac ist es auch ein bisschen Frickelzeug, allerdings sind die dort deutlich einheitlicher.
Ja, gut, unter Linux lassen wir es mal komplett aus und vor.
Aber Linux hat ja beim Desktop wenig Bedeutung.
Dass die ganzen Electron-Desktop-Anwendungen sich so durchgesetzt haben,
liegt einfach daran, weil es Microsoft GUI-mäßig zum größten Teil verkackt hat.
Wären Electron-Anwendungen auf Windows eine nicht akzeptierte Anwendungsspezies,
dann hätten die sich nie durchgesetzt.
Windows ist die Plattform, die es zu supporten gilt auf dem Desktop,
wenn man erfolgreich sein will.
Und das Ganze wurde dadurch halt begünstigt,
dass immer mehr Sachen Cross-Plattform werden sollten.
Allerdings, Microsoft halt kein ordentliches GUI-Framework für Windows hatte
und man musste Windows halt mitsupporten.
Man hat mal gesagt, okay, das Einfachste ist,
wir nehmen einfach einen Browser und verpacken ihn in ein eigenes Fenster.
Ja, auf mobile ist das weniger ein Problem,
aber da ist auch ziemlich Wildwuchs auf mobile.
Das Einzige, wo man wirklich sagen kann, auf mobile gibt es eine klare Sache,
ist, wenn man die jeweiligen native Geschichten verwendet,
also sprich, wenn man Swift und, wie heißt das,
dieses iOS-native-Zeug-Kit-Gramm verwendet,
dann ist das relativ klar.
Und wenn man das Android-Java-Gedöns verwendet, dann auch.
Spätestens, wenn man irgendwelche Cross-Plattform-Sachen nimmt,
dann React Native oder Ionic oder Flutter jetzt neuerdings,
dann ist das, oder Kotlin für Android kann man auch nehmen,
dann ist das auch schon wieder mehr oder weniger Web-Gedöns,
was mit der Plattform wenig zu tun hat.
Und hier spekuliere ich ja darauf,
dass das Microsoft endlich mal hinbekommen könnte,
ein neues GUI-Framework zu releasen,
was tatsächlich breit für alle Anwendungen unter Windows gedacht ist und funktioniert.
Das haben die seit 20 Jahren halt hingekriegt.
So, ich hab irgendwas im Hals heute.
So, und...
Leider gibt es doch kein festes Release-Datum.
Es gibt eine Alpha-Version davon,
die allerdings noch nicht die Desktop-Komponente enthält,
was ziemlich doof ist, weil ohne Desktop-Komponente kann man das Wichtigste nicht ausprobieren.
Gibt es Screenshots? Na, es sieht aus wie UWP.
Es sieht standardmäßig aus wie UWP, also so wie der Crap hier.
Es ist ja im Endeffekt das weiterentwickelte UWP-GUI.
Hallo? Taschenrechner?
Windows, please!
Warum schaffst du es nicht, ein Taschenrechner zu starten?
Das ist ein fucking Taschenrechner, Windows!
Hat jemand schon mal erlebt, dass eine Taschenrechner-App kaputtgehen kann?
Was ist mit Windows los manchmal? Versteh...
Oh, RIP. RIP.
Oh, mein ganzes GUI ist RIP, Leute.
Mein ganzes Windows-GUI ist RIP, weil der Taschenrechner RIP ist.
Oh nee.
Oh je, Leute, mein GUI geht nicht mehr. Meine Windows-Shell ist kaputt.
Alt-Tab geht auch nicht mehr.
RIP.
Oh je.
Was war ich denn jetzt? Task-Manager.
Okay.
Okay, oh je, und jetzt? Explorer abschießen.
Explorer.
Bam.
Wow. Was ist das?
Ist jetzt der Tank? Und Kalk.
Kalk.
Ach du Scheiße.
Explorer.
Ah, yes. Excellent.
Windows, Alter.
Ich hab den Taschenrechner gestartet.
Damit konnte keiner rechnen, dass ich den Taschenrechner starte.
Mal gucken, ob der Taschenrechner jetzt funktioniert.
Ah, da ist er wieder.
Funktioniert.
Hat irgendjemand eine logische Erklärung dafür, warum ein Windows-Desktop gerade abgeschissen ist,
weil ich den Taschenrechner geöffnet hab?
Irgendeine logische, sinnvolle Erklärung?
Ich hab eine Idee. Ich weiß, woran das lag.
Ich war doch vorher in den Display-Settings.
Ich mach keine Bug-Meldungen dafür, dass der...
Also, da bin ich mir... da ist mir das echt zu schade für.
Vor allem, wie soll man das reproduzierbar machen?
Ich mach doch keinen Bug-Report dafür, dass der Taschenrechner mit Windows-Desktop crasht.
Wenn ich den aufmache, ist das so ein typisches Issue, was geschlossen wird mit zu wenig Information.
Was soll ich dabei sagen?
Aber ich glaubt, wir gucken mal, ob wir das nachvollziehen können.
Das Problem war, ich hab das hier ganz oft geöffnet.
Ich hab das hier ganz oft geöffnet.
Und dann den Taschenrechner.
Oh, und dann hab ich das zugemacht.
Und danach war der Taschenrechner kaputt.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Ob das wieder der Fall ist.
Genau, Systemsteuerung hatte ich noch auf.
Hab da irgendwie drin rumgesucht.
Okay, und jetzt hab ich den Taschenrechner geöffnet.
Hab den Taschenrechner geschlossen.
Einmal ging er.
Zweimal war er...
Nee, okay.
Ist nicht nachvollziehbar.
No history...
Oh, mein Taschenrechner hat eine history.
Huge.
Nee, eher hier.
Schick denen das Wort.
Nee, sollen sich um den Scheiß kümmern.
Macht da nicht mit.
Ja, Leute, und seid ihr wach?
Kann ich den Stream wieder ausmachen?
Battlefield 4, 400 Locker-Kills.
Sind wahrscheinlich übelste Kacknoob-Gegner.
Könnte wieder nappen.
Fingerprint RFID Lock Defeated with a Paper Clip.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Das sieht nach excellent big brain Content aus für morgens.
Ist zu leise oder geht?
Leise.
Das ist besser, oder?
Was?
Moment, wo?
Ach, da.
Ich habe jetzt dahin geguckt, weil er hier sein Finger hingehalten hat.
Aber da macht er das ja.
Oder?
Ja.
Das ist bestimmt so ein AliExpress-Schloss.
Lass mich mal raten.
Das Schloss ist wahrscheinlich nicht die Schwachstelle bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Wahrscheinlich ist das Schloss gar nicht das Problem, sondern hier der Scheiß drum herum.
Oh, big brain Passwort.
Aber das Passwort ist eigentlich falsch.
Das Passwort muss 123456 sein.
Nur dann ist es secure genug.
Strom ausmachen?
Das ganze Ding geht auf.
Gehe ich mal von aus so.
Ah.
Okay, im Prinzip wird nicht hier irgendwas verschlüsseltes übertragen, sondern einfach
nur auf-zu.
Also sprich, wenn man an das Kabel dran kommt, ist es eigentlich vollkommen egal.
Wenn ich verstehe, was er sagen will.
Es 500, 500
Hier ist eine Schraube, die die Schraube aufhält.
Als ich die Schraube entferne, sollte ich bemerken, dass solche Geräte einen Anti-Tamper-Schraub haben.
Diesen Schraub aber nicht, und wenn er tatsächlich ist, sind sie ziemlich einfach zu überwinden.
Als ich auf den Inneren schaue...
Warum hat es hier einen RJ-45-Stecker, oder ist das ein RJ-11-Stecker?
Nein, das ist ein RJ-11-Stecker.
Ich sehe vier Schrauben, eine rote und eine schwarze, die unser Macht und Grund sind. Dann haben wir eine blühe und eine orangen.
Diese blühen und orangenen Schrauben sind als...
Keep talking and nobody explodes? Das könnte es sein, ja. Genau, genau. Ich glaube, das Game ist richtig nice, wenn man das mit den richtigen Leuten spielt.
Aber nachdem ich ja keine ARL-Freunde habe, kann ich das mit keinem spielen.
Nur mit dem Twitch-Chat.
Ich habe den Fabian schon öfters versucht zu überreden, mal irgendwelche anderen Games zu spielen, aber da will er nicht mehr.
Der Master-Crabber, ich weiß nicht, was der gerade crabt, mit dem kannst du anschreiben, der antwortet nicht mal mehr.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Oh fuck, Alter. Oh, mein Streaming-Rechner ist abgekackt, Leute. Und die Soundcard hat übelsten RIP-Sound von sich gegeben, ey.
ETF. Oh, mein Ohr. Ich sehe jetzt übrigens den Chat nicht. Nur so angemerkt, ich sehe den Chat nicht.
Muss mein Streaming-Rechner neu starten. Mache mal hier den Chat auf, damit ich den Chat...
Freiheit. Ich sehe euch wieder, Leute. Muss gerade mal das Tastaturumstöpsel in den Rechner neu starten. Wo wir gerade beim Thema Windows und komische Dinger sind.
Windows-Rechner ist Wonka-Smoke. Startet er heute noch mal? Ah, jetzt.
So, es dauert jetzt zwei Minuten, bis der Streaming-Rechner wieder gestartet ist. Also Streaming-Rechner ist ja bescheuert, ich streame von dem Rechner, aber mein Rechner mit Vorschau, Emote-Control und allem Möglichen.
Ja, wir müssen dann nochmal zurückspulen und uns das fertig angucken, weil ich habe jetzt nicht aufgepasst, weil mein Rechner abgekackt ist.
Das Video mit der Box, die man auf eine Ecke schlagen kann, haben wir schon ange... Was? Hä?
Ich weiß nicht, was du meinst. Ach, du meinst das Schloss, das man aufmachen kann von denen. Ja, das haben wir schon geguckt.
Das haben wir schon geguckt.
Ok, ich glaube der Rechner ist wieder gestartet.
Jawoll, aber ich komme mal mit der Tastatur nicht rüber. Warum nicht?
Please, Windows, Windows, please, lass mich auf meinen anderen Rechner zugreifen.
Windows, ich will auf den anderen Rechner.
Darf nicht. Normalerweise kann ich meine Maus nach links schieben jetzt. Wartet mal.
Connected. Ah, jetzt funktioniert es, sehr gut.
Aber da irgendwas im Hintergrund?
Ach ne, das gehört zur Kirby-Musik.
Moin, Dr. Evil Cookie.
Der Rechner startet jetzt. Mal gucken, wie lange er braucht.
Dieses Video glaube ich war letzte Woche.
Ich glaube das haben wir, bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob wir das schon geguckt haben.
Du kannst mit einer Maus beide PCs steuern. Ja, mit dem Ding hier.
Maus without borders. Das da.
Es gibt noch ein paar andere, es gibt sogar Programme, da kannst du Linux und Windows
übergreifen, steuern, so mit Synergy oder was noch alles gibt.
Das ist ganz praktisch. Das ist offiziell von Microsoft kostenlos.
Hast du die Kontroverse über Warcraft Reforged mitbekommen? Klar.
Natürlich. Haben wir uns nicht letztes Wochenende sogar ein Video zu angeguckt?
Wir sehen eigentlich gerade so die Metacritic Forged. Wie sieht es denn da gerade so aus?
So, ich gucke jetzt mal, ob ich auf dem zweiten Rechner wieder den Kram gestartet kriege.
Restore. Ja, funktioniert, sehr gut.
Alter, mein USB Soundkarte macht jetzt Geräusche. Was ist mit dem Rechner los?
Warte mal, ich muss mal rausziehen.
Und wieder rein machen. What the fuck, Alter, was ist hier los gerade?
So. Hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo. Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, ich glaube, jetzt geht es wieder. Schmeiß weg.
Das ist eine 800 Euro und 800 Euro Audio Interface oder was auch immer der Scheiß gekostet hat.
Das darf nicht einfach so kaputt gehen.
Der Crash-Fluffy, hast du genug Punkte gesagt?
Das ist ja cool, dass man Wub-S mit Glutflecken fahren kann.
Okay, wunderbar. Also, was hat denn Reforged für Metacritics aktuell?
0,5. Das wird ja immer schlechter.
Das letzte Mal, wo wir geguckt haben, hat es so 1,2. 0,5. Okay, das ist echt mies.
Aber Blizzard hat es auch mega verschössener.
Blizzard hat sich mal wieder richtig in die Scheiße geredet.
Das habe ich nicht mitgekriegt. Ich habe nur mitbekommen, dass die Leute wieder Shocking-Interview-Memes machen.
Shocking-Interview-Memes gehen immer nur, wenn einer sich richtig in die Scheiße setzt.
Das beste Audio Interface hier. Das Ding habe ich seit Jahren schon.
Koste aktuell... Okay, kostet nur... Vielleicht hat es auch nur 400 Euro gekostet, aber es war teuer.
Refunds werden teilweise nicht gegeben, obwohl sie gesagt haben, sie refunden.
Und sie haben gesagt bei Blizzard, das habe ich auch mitgekriegt, was die Leute richtig darüber aufgeregt haben,
das Spiel wäre quasi nur so schlecht, weil man auf Fan-Feedback gehörte.
Sie haben es versucht, auf die Fans abzuwälzen, nach dem Motto, die Fans wollten ja, dass es schlecht wird.
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal das Shocking-Interview an. Die Dinger sind eigentlich immer ganz lustig.
Ich habe hier auch mal eins hochgeladen. Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern?
Ich habe hier auch mal ein Shocking-Interview mit Call of Duty-Developer hochgeladen.
Das habe ich dann aber gelöscht, das Video.
Das habe ich dann aber gelöscht.
Weil damals dieser spanische Fernsehsender, wo das herkam...
Na klar, hier, kennt ihr das nicht mal.
Interview...
Das da.
Das hat irgendjemand anderes dann hochgeladen, der das Video kopiert hat.
Unglaubliches Interview zu Call of Duty 2015 mit Entwickler.
So, okay, wir gucken mal was wir machen. Die Dinger sind eigentlich immer ganz lustig.
Man muss sie da nicht wirklich verstehen. Es ist halt nicht lustig für alle, die spanisch können.
Die Variante kenne ich jetzt noch nicht, aber das gibt es dazu zig Sachen.
Der Scheiß wird nicht alt, ey.
Eigentlich ist der Text noch nicht mal lustig. Der Text ist noch nicht mal lustig.
Aber irgendwie wird das nicht alt, der Scheiß.
Der Text ist noch nicht mal richtig lustig.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Sie haben das komplette originale Spiel kaputt gemacht.
Was? Chat ist im Weg. Der Chat.
Was, echt? Der Chat im Weg?
Alter, das USB-Interface spackt wieder rum.
Warum kackt das so ab?
WTF, hört ihr das knacken?
Das ist voll am abscheißen gerade.
Okay, ich glaube jetzt hat es sich wieder eingekriegt.
Okay, Chat, ich muss kurz mal den Chat ausmachen und dann gucken wir uns das nochmal an.
Aber wie gesagt, der Text ist eigentlich gar nicht das lustige. Der Text ist sogar relativ unlustig, das ist halt einfach die Wahrheit.
Und das geile ist, ich habe ja in meinem Call of Duty Interview fast genau den gleichen Gag gebracht, der bietet sich einfach an.
Das ist so dumm.
Das haben sie voll verkackt.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr über was der im Original redet? Ich habe mal ein Video zugesehen, über was der im Original redet.
Der redet, dass er irgendwelche, ich glaube irgendwelche Pfannen oder so an den Strand gestellt hat und die sind dann irgendwie weggespült worden.
Das Original ist genau so bescheuert.
Genau wie er Töpfe im Meer versenkt hat, genau.
Ja, Fett, Alter.
Ist das echt so?
Das ist ja immer so.
Das ist das, das ist das, ey, dass das neue UI nicht im Spiel drin ist, das ist eine der Sachen, wo sie behauptet haben, ja das haben wir gemacht, weil die Fans, die Fans möchten das so.
Ich weiß ja nicht, ob da was, das klingt ein bisschen vorgeschoben.
Das frage ich mich auch, das frage ich mich auch.
Wir müssen uns jetzt gleich mal die Activision Blizzard Aktie angucken, ob die irgendwie, ob man das sieht.
Stunks, genau.
Warte mal, Activision Blizzard Aktie.
Naja.
Nicht wirklich, oder?
Hier, hier hinten ein bisschen.
Aber nicht wirklich, die Stunks sind gut hier.
Den Shitstorm, das interessiert auch keinen, die interessiert nur, ob der Kram verkauft wird oder nicht.
Bei den Stunks sieht man das nicht.
Wollen wir noch, wollen wir noch mein Video mal angucken, was ich mal dazu gemacht, also nicht so eine Blizzard Geschichte, sondern ich habe irgendein Video, ich weiß gar nicht mehr zu was.
Ich habe, ich habe mal irgendein Video zu, was war Call of Duty 2015 nochmal?
Was war Call of Duty 2015? Oh, ich habe Subs übersehen.
Hi Noob, Stufe 1, 12 Monate, Dankeschön.
So ein Alex, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich muss mal kurz schauen, ob ich, ach Black Ops 3 war das, ok.
Steamlabs, ich muss mal kurz gucken, ich glaube ich habe ein paar Subs vergessen.
Recent Events, Subs, ne habe ich nicht, ok, alles gut.
Gibt es was Gutes, dass man sich bei AliExpress spontan bestellen kann?
Es kommt drauf an, ob du dich für Elektronikkram interessierst oder nicht.
Du kannst dir die Xiaomi Wage bestellen mit Bluetooth, da kannst du dann immer den automatischen Graph malen lassen, ob du abnimmst oder nicht.
So, wir gucken uns jetzt mal mein Video an von 2015.
Was?
Es ist halt schon ein bisschen älter, ne?
Sie sind leise.
Und es ist zwei, es ist drei Jahre, es ist fünf Jahre später.
Es ist drei Jahre, es ist fünf Jahre später immer noch das gleiche, fünf Jahre später exakt das gleiche.
Das ist auch jedes Jahr das gleiche, jedes Jahr das gleiche.
Es ist halt einfach die Wahrheit.
So ist es, es ist einfach so, immer noch so fünf Jahre später.
Es ist einfach das gleiche, jedes Jahr das gleiche, jedes Jahr das gleiche, jedes Jahr das gleiche.
Es ist einfach das gleiche, jedes Jahr das gleiche, jedes Jahr das gleiche.
So dumm.
Mittlerweile haben sie es ja geschafft, wenigstens das haben sie mittlerweile geschafft.
Das kannst du echt, also 90% der Sachen kannst du für jedes neue Call of Duty verwenden, oder?
90% der Sachen, fünf Jahre später passt 90% der Sachen, passt aktuell, einfach immer noch ganz genau so, ja?
Das einzige mit Dedicated Servers, gut, das haben sie jetzt geschafft.
Wir wollten, bricht das Video mit dem Schloss fertig gucken, fallen wir gerade ein.
Irgendwie sind wir da nicht dazu gekommen.
Okay, wie macht ihr denn jetzt das Schloss auf?
Nick, sechs Monate in Folge, danke schön, huge, huge prime sub, oder richtig, echter sub.
Huge, hi IQ, Subscriber.
Also im Prinzip schraube ich auf, nehme irgendwas Leitendes, im Zweifelsfall irgendwie so ein Stück, keine Ahnung, gedrehte Alufolie oder so, und stecke das rein.
It's really just that easy. So, as you saw, despite the intimidating high tech appearance, bypassing this is just as easy as opening a simple mechanical lock.
In any case, that's all I have for you today, if you do have any questions or comments about this, please put them below.
In dem Fall tatsächlich, wie ich vermutet habe, das Schloss ist gar nicht so sehr das Problem, sondern er kramt drum herum. Huge chat.
Luthorax, Twitch Prime, danke schön für den Sub.
Habe ich euch eigentlich schon erzählt, was man schönes mit seinem Amazon Prime Account machen kann, wenn man ihn mit Twitch verknüpft.
Wenn ihr euren Amazon Account nämlich mit Twitch verknüpft, könnt ihr einen Streamer eurer Wahl kostenlos mit einem Tier 1 Sub unterstützen.
Freuen sich alle Beteiligten drüber.
No shit.
Ähm, sind wir stehen geblieben.
Achja komm, komm, wir gucken jetzt mal, wir gucken jetzt noch mal eine Runde Battlefield Top Plays.
Irgendwie, irgendwie Istmas dazu. Genau, Any Primers.
Wir gucken, wir gucken noch eine Runde Battlefield Top Plays.
I.G.Sutz, klingt, klingt wie irgendein schlechter Rapper.
I.G.Sutz, I.
Okay.
Vorbei.
Was hat der für einen Lack?
Das war ja hier Lack of Doom.
So, jetzt, jetzt müsste eigentlich der Hit kommen. Wenn überhaupt müsste jetzt der Hit kommen.
What the fuck? Was ist das?
Battlefield 3 Hitboxen.
Und, und, und, und, kriegt er seinen Chat noch? Kriegt er seinen Chat noch?
Oh nice, nice. Ich hab eigentlich gedacht, der kriegt seinen alten Chat noch.
Das wär natürlich richtig cool gewesen. Und richtig nice, richtig nice wärs jetzt gewesen.
Er schießt den anderen Chat ab und dann kommt er zufällig noch in seinen alten Chat rein.
Das wär absolut huge, huge gewesen. Aber so ist auch schon nice.
Okay, commentary, eigentlich, eigentlich würd ich mir die Videos fast ohne commentary angucken,
weil er sagt echt jedes Mal genau das gleiche. Und ich sag jedes Mal, dass er jedes Mal das gleiche sagt.
Und ich sag jedes Mal, dass er jedes Mal das gleiche sagt.
Ups.
F?
EF.
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Ihr jebaitet mich.
Der Chat, der Chat jebaitet mich.
Ich hab ne Vorschau, Leute. Der Stream ging die ganze Zeit.
Oh, es laggt, es laggt echt.
Nee, es laggt überhaupt nicht.
Good, good wieder.
Das war, wisst ihr was, das war eines der geilsten Sachen in Bad Company 2.
So richtig nice AT-4-Shots.
Okay, das war schon ein bisschen lagg.
Die Gegner sind mal wieder absolut dämlich und checken nix.
Der Shield, Dude, was geht mit dem ab?
Die Treffen ja nix. Guck mal, da standen noch 5 Gegner rum. Es ist nix passiert.
Was, Bild laggt?
Oh ja, Bild laggt.
Äh, Sekunde Leute.
Ja, äh, ich glaub Twitch hat Probleme. Oder Unity Media.
Oder, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oder Unity Media, eins von beiden.
Sturmtief Sabine ist am Start, genau.
Speedtest, ich mach mal nen Speedtest und guck mal ob das ähm...
Ja, Sabine ist schuld.
Nicht dass, nicht dass jetzt hier Terministen ankommen.
Ich mach grad mal nen Speedtest nebenbei, das sieht gut aus.
Es sind zwar nur 280mbit down anstatt 400, aber ist okay.
So, und jetzt gucken wir mal Upload.
Jetzt kann der Stream gleich mal ruckeln, weil ich Upload-Tests mache.
Nee, passt, alles gut. 36mbit, kein Problem, passt.
Das ist Twitch, das ist Twitch, der rumspackt.
Oder aber das Routing zu Twitch, eins von beiden, spackt rum.
Da kann ich leider nichts machen jetzt.
Wir hoffen einfach mal es funktioniert wieder.
So, und jetzt ist es endlich wieder ein
...
Oder ist noch gar nichts passiert?
Ich glaube es ist noch gar nichts passiert.
Hä?
Achso, der schießt jetzt den Jet mit der TV-Misswahl ab.
Was macht der da?
Ah, jetzt trifft er ihn, oder?
Hahaha!
Oh, das war nice!
Das war cool!
So hatten wir auch ziemlich glücklich, aber das war nice.
Oh!
Was ist hier los?
Chat!
Was, was ist jetzt los hier?
Und ganz ohne Hype-Train, der Hi-Noob verschenkt 5 Stufe 1 Abos, Dankeschön, huge, hyper,
hyper, ich weiß gar nicht wie das riecht, Hyper S, genau, ich weiß gar nicht wie das
richtige E-Mote dafür da ist.
Dankeschön für die gegifteten Subs, wen haben wir da, wer kriegt denn alle Subs?
C2HO, die Erkenntnis, oh, das ist aber ein exquisite philosophischer Name, die Erkenntnis
hat ein Abo gekriegt, NachoLibre, Jazzheimer und BigLul91, Ihr Hi-Noob, Dankeschön für
die ganzen Subs, Hi-IQ-Chat heute wieder.
300 Zuschauer Twitch Vertrag Incoming, nee nee Mixer, Ebolon 5 Monate, Dankeschön.
Wisst ihr was ich ja ein bisschen merkwürdig finde, dass die meisten Leute zugucken wenn
ich YouTube Reaction Videos mache, YouTube Reaction Streamer, aber ich kann mich nicht
beschweren, ja das andere ist ja auch komplettes Nischen Zeug was ich da mache und das da auch
teilweise um die 200 Leute am Start sind ist auch schon huge, aber sonntags wenn ich irgendwie
einfach nur auf YouTube gehe und Video Reaction mache BAM gibt's Views, auch noch mehr hier,
auch wieder Medics, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, IQ Sub, Reactions sind aktuell am beliebtesten,
ja guckt euch unge an, da ist nix mehr übrig von dem Channel wie es mal ursprünglich gewesen
ist, Hauptsache Reaction Videos und ich verstehe nicht warum man Reaction Videos so gerne guckt,
aber jeder was er will, Michael das kann auch sein, eine Maus vibriert, macht sie das,
so weiter, das stimmt, das stimmt, es ist auch gar nicht so einfach dahin zu kommen,
ich muss euch ehrlich sagen ich bin mir sogar unschlüssig wie mein Team Deathmatch dahin
kommt, wie kommt mein Team Deathmatch dahum, dahin, mit falschem, ja gut aber von wo
von wo, im Team Deathmatch, in Team Deathmatch hast, ah nach Spawnbieken, falschem das stimmt,
stimmt, an Spawnbieken hab ich gar nicht gedacht, ja dann ist klar wie man dahin kommt, weil
ich wollt grad sagen im TDM hast du hier gar keine Helis, Spawnbieken, falschem, stimmt,
dementsprechend kriegst du den ja da auch nicht richtig raus, der Waffensound, der Waffensound
und die Animation und so das Gefühl, ich finde das ist mit Bad Company 2 und Battlefield
3, fast, haben sie nicht mehr in der Form erreicht, passt einfach alles, technical headshots,
das waren nicht einfach nur Headshots Leute, das waren tactical Headshots, das ist genau
so, ich hab mir bei Amazon ein Multifunktions Tool bestellt, also quasi das ist ein Messer,
ne Schraubendreher, ne Schere ist dran, Dosenöffnhalt, halt das war es früher, das war es früher,
Taschenmesser war halt bloß, ich kanns ja mal kurz zeigen, so und seitdem ich das bestellt
habe, was Multifunktions, sowas hier, sowas hier hab ich mir bestellt ja, da hat man auch
so ne Bitsammlung und so, das ist unglaublich praktisch, wenn man irgendwo hin muss, beispielsweise
in Stall oder in die Garage oder so und man weiß, man braucht vielleicht ein bisschen
Werkzeug für Sachen und man weiß noch nicht genau was, das ist wirklich praktisch und
seitdem ich mir das Ding hier bestellt habe, kriege ich Werbung von Amazon, für Tactical
Equipment die ganze Zeit und letztens, glaubt es nicht, hat mir Amazon empfohlen, ich soll
mir einen, es ist kein Witz, Tactical Tomahawk kaufen, ich wusste gar nicht, dass es ernsthaft,
dass es Tactical Tomahawks gibt, warum um alles in der Welt gibt es Tactical Tomahawk
und vor allem, was mach ich mit einem Tactical Tomahawk und was ist an einem Tactical Tomahawk
besser als an einem normalen Axt, ich glaube, dass wenn es um Waffen und Messer und so gedürnt
geht, dass Tactical quasi das ist, was RGB bei Gamer Equipment ist, ja bei Gamer Equipment
ist überall RGB, egal wie unsinnig oder nicht und bei Messer, Waffen und sonstwas ist Tactical
das Ding, weil wenn man was anpreisen möchte, dann ist es kein Tomahawk, sondern ein Tactical
Tomahawk, ich frag mich halt auch, ob das, genau, so ein Alex habe ich auch gerade dran
gedacht, vielleicht läuft der auf Kubernetes oder so, der Tomahawk, ja das ist Tactical,
zumindest, um mal zu hören, das Ding kann ich echt empfehlen, das ist wirklich sehr praktisch,
das ist zwar auch eben so ein China Ding, ich glaube sogar, das ist das, was ich bestellt
habe oder das, ne, das da, das ist echt praktisch, wenn man keine Ahnung hat, was man für Werkzeug
braucht, man hat einfach alles dabei und es ist erstaunlich stabil, ne, es ist erstaunlich
stabil das ganze Ding und sogar der Bitsatz macht einen ganz guten Eindruck, also für
17,99 kann man da echt nichts, echt nichts falsch machen, ich habe das jetzt schon ein
paar mal benutzt, einfach weil ich, weil ich es mitgenommen habe, weil ich wusste, ok,
ich brauche wahrscheinlich ein bisschen Werkzeug und da hast du alles dabei, oh, das Scamtrain
Stufe 2 ist erreicht, Dankeschön, Scamtrain, äh, nein, Hypetrain natürlich, ähm, huge
hype und so, ne, was hat man da eigentlich davon, wenn der Scamtrain, ähm, erfolgreich
ist, kriegt man irgendwelche Emotes, oder, ich habe mir das noch nie angeguckt, man bekommt
Emotes, ah ja, stehe, exquisite Emotes hoffe ich, aber Pepe Emotes können es nicht sein,
weil Pepe Emotes gehen auf Twitch nicht, nicht auf offiziellen Twitch, weil Pepe Emotes
sind ja schon quasi fast schon Hatespeech, das kann man nicht, das geht nicht, selbst
das hier, selbst das hier Leute, obwohl es nicht so aussieht, obwohl es nicht so aussieht,
na, das geht schon als Hatespeech durch, ein Pepe mit einem Herzchen, oh, ich wurde gehostet,
Commander Krieger 474 ist eine schöne Zuschauerzahl, Dankeschön für den Host, huge, big brain,
high IQ Host, Wahnsinn, ähm, viel Spaß und schön vor mir, ich wünsche es dir auch, ja,
nice, nice Sache, hallo Leute, ähm, die vom Krieger rüber gekommen sind, weiß nicht,
was ihr gerade so getrieben habt, aber, ähm, wir gucken uns sinnlose YouTube Videos an,
unter anderem Battlefield Top Plays und ich gebe meinen Senf dazu, also, bester Reaction
Content, ne, so wie das zurzeit angesagt ist, alter, spielst du Battlefield, nein, ich guck
nur ein Battlefield Video, mehr Viewer für high IQ Reaction Streams, so siehts aus, geht
nach oben, Stonks, alter, spielst du Battlefield, äh, hab ich, nein, nicht und Battlefield 1
auch nicht und Battlefield 5, äh, gar nicht, ähm, ok, gucken wir mal, oh, da hat er jetzt
aber, hat er jetzt, also, der 2 jetzt aber nix, bam, oh, das ist ein
Tripple Palastral, oh, das ist nice, hast du noch Kontakt zu Kaboom an der Serial ETC,
äh, vereinzelt, ja, vereinzelt, aber das, das war kein Tactical 360, das war kein, kein
Tactical 360, die Gegner sind mal wieder richtig, oi,
Pipega Gegner, aber die Waffen fühlen sich wie Battlefield 3, selbst, selbst beim Zugucken,
sag doch mal Leute, jetzt, jetzt, wo so viele neue gerade im Chat dazugekommen sind, ähm,
an alle die Battlefield 3 gespielt haben, hat es ihr in irgendeinem anderen Battlefield,
nach Battlefield 3, wieder das, ähm, das Feeling, also, die Kombination aus Waffen,
Sound, Animation, äh, Handling und Gameplay, wie sich das in Kombination angefühlt hat,
hatten ihr das, kam euch das jemals irgendwie, halt, hart leider,
BF4, ok, ja, Battlefield 4 war nah dran, das stimmt, Battlefield 4 war nah dran, das
richtet, ich, ich würde Battlefield 3 und Battlefield 4, mittlerweile, Battlefield 4
hat sich ja unglaublich viel getan, auch nach Release, würde ich fast schon so auf
einer, auf einer Stufe sehen, ähm, allerdings sind die Rushmaps in Battlefield 3 deutlich
besser, ähm, aber, aber, generell, ich, ich finde es halt, das ist beim Zugucken, allein
schon wenn ich die Nachladeanimation sehe mit der Sniper, ähm, das passt einfach alles,
das Klicken dann, richtig nice, aber vielleicht einfach weil ich das 1000 schon immer so
gespielt habe, aber auch auf allen Plattformen, bam, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das
hat er, das hat er nicht predicted, der hat eventuell grob erahnt, dass der da langfliegen
könnte, aber predicted war das nicht, das kann er mir nicht erzählen, dass das predicted
war, das ist ungefähr, das ist ungefähr genau so predicted, wie wenn ich weiß, ähm,
im gegnerischen, in der gegnerischen Base, sporten ein Panzer oder ein Flieger und ich
schieß grob in Richtung der gegnerischen Base und der fliegt dann halt voll rein, es
ist ungefähr genau so predicted, old skill, no luck, genau, easy, easy as fuck, so hydranten
sieben Monate, dankeschön, oh, sellout mode, wir überspringen den sellout mode mal, besteht
dieser shop nur, nur irgendwie komplett aus, aus battlefield, ja, trust the mechanic fragt,
kennt jemand einen trick um battlefield 3 wieder zu spielen, hab windows 10 64 mit und
es crash bei mir während des loading screens, also ich hatte mal das problem, allerdings
war das beim joinen von multiplayer spielen, dass mein punkbuster irgendwie nicht richtig
mehr funktioniert hat in windows 10, da musste ich mir von irgendeiner, ich glaube von origin
selbst, irgendwo musste ich mir eine ural punkbuster version herunterladen für battle
und dann hat es funktioniert, das war aber nicht beim starten vom game, das war beim
joinen von multiplayer spielen, also sprich, ich bin ins battle log gegangen, hab einen
server ausgewählt, hab gejoint und quasi, fast nachdem ich im spiel war, war halt das
spiel im arsch, das hatten so viele, genau das ist mein problem, ja dann guck mal, guck
mal, das ist das punkbuster nicht richtig läuft, muss man nachgucken, keine garantie,
dass das funktioniert und ich übernehme keine haftung für schäden an einem rechner, aber
probiere das mal mit punkbuster aus und suche mal danach, kannste eine runde googeln, das
problem hatte ich auch mal, ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist doch gar keine AIK, diese
komische war von der, ich hab sie so gut wie nie, kann mich gerade erinnern, dass ich die
mal gespielt hab, das ist doch, ist das nicht die sniper, ist das nicht die sniper SMG gewesen,
war das nicht die sniper SMG, ja ja genau, ha, der Gegner, die checken war wieder gar
nix, also manche gegner, manche gegner frage ich mich echt, was die gemacht haben, sitzen
die falsch rum vor monitor, balancieren die irgendwie die tastatur, wisst ihr manche gegner
kommen mir so vor, als haben sie die tastatur nicht auf dem schreibtisch stehen, sondern
balancieren die so auf dem kopf und haben dann ihre hände oben drauf, ungefähr so wirkt
das wie manche reagieren, hast du schon OI im memetool, ne hab ich nicht, das liegt aber
daran, weil ich bisher noch keine etwas höhere aufgelöste version von OI gefunden hab, also
keine hochaufgelöste 3 head version, ich spiel mit einem lenkrad, kennt ihr noch, kennt ihr
noch das, kennt ihr das noch, killed by a wheel, see a score, moment, was ist das, ich
glaub das ist es, ne das ist es nicht, das ist es nicht, oh man jetzt find ich das video
nicht, es gab irgenso ein cs video, wo einer mit nem lenkrad gespielt hat, p90 rumgesprayed
und die gegner gekettet hat, kill to it, ne, ne, ne, ne, das ist es, ah egal, das erste,
ne das ist es nicht, das war nur ein ganz kurzer clip, das waren so zu 1.30 oder so, das fand
ich halt auch echt nice, gucken wir noch ein bisschen battlefield, schon wieder, schon
wieder der jesus, der ist aber aktiv heute, was ist denn das, das ps4, das sieht so verschwommen
aus, ps4 oder ist das gar noch, ne ps3 kann es nicht sein, das ist battlefield 4, ja das
ist ps4, ja wahrscheinlich wird er jetzt, wahrscheinlich wird er jetzt gekickt, ich
wurde auch schon so oft gekickt in diesem, ja genau, ich pepega gegner und vor allem
pepega admins, ich pepega admins, das geht mir auch immer auf den kicks, ich wurde auch
schon so oft grundlos gebannt und ich frag mich wie es als richtig guten spielern geht,
wenn ich mir die gameplay von der hexe beispielsweise angucke, der muss ja laufen gebannt werden,
ich meine wenn die mich schon bannen und der ist einfach mal 500% noch mal besser, der
ist ja wahrscheinlich, vor allem so auch mal ein perma bunt, ja herr kracht muss ja prinzipiell
schon, also ich finde es auch besser wenn es ordentlich gemanagte customservers sind,
beispielsweise konnte man ja in battlefield 3 und in battlefield 2, in battlefield 4 teilweise
auch noch glaube ich sowas wie ein ordentliches sniper limit machen und sowas was dafür gesorgt
hat, dass die runden viel viel viel angenehmer zu spielen waren, sniper limit wäre einfach
auf zwei leute limitieren, dann hast du auch nicht das problem in rush gehabt, dass keiner
rushed und jetzt ist halt das problem, dass es halt keiner so richtig mehr macht und es
nicht lohnt, ja, ein ordentlich gemoddeter, administrierter battlefield 3, 4, pet company
2 also aber das war gut, welche die dich halt nicht gebannt haben nur weil du gut gespielt
hast, autobalance plugins waren gar nicht übel wenn die ordentlich eingestellt waren,
man konnte die autobalance plugins so einstellen, dass sie respektiert haben wenn leute gegroupt
haben und man konnte autobalance plugins auch so einstellen, dass sie so gut wie nie in
der runde extrem gebalanced haben, sondern nur quasi die teams nach der runde so verteilt
haben, also man konnte, es gab ja nicht so viele, man konnte die schon ganz okay einstellen,
ja und eine sache, die ich auch prinzipiell nicht gemocht habe ist die sache, dass du
quasi vip slots hattest, die leute random vom server gekickt haben und so, dass man spielen
konnte, das fand ich doof, ich bin der meinung wer zuerst auf dem server drauf war sollte
halt auch spielen, das ist gut, das ist echt nicht schlecht, das lasse ich mir jetzt gefallen
wenn da einer sagt, der hat das predicted, das glaube ich dem sogar, dass vorher der
rpg auf den chat da war einfach glück, aber dass das predicted war und halt der gegner
auch da mit gespielt hat, oh katze was machst du da oben, meine katze schmeißt gleich zeug
vom schrank, chico, chico was machst du da, chico das ist kein, gleich fällt was runter,
dann guckste wieder, chico was machst du da, warte mal ich muss mal kurz meine katze, muss
mal kurz die katze vom schrank holen, muss mal kurz die katze vom schrank holen.
ich glaube es geht los, jetzt wolltest du mir den finger beißen, weil ich sie
runter geschoben habe vom schrank, so weiter, wir spielen jetzt nicht, jetzt rollt sie sich
auf dem schrank rum, wir spielen eine runde, das geht jetzt nicht, chico wir müssen ein
hartes reaction business machen hier, oh Leute ich muss euch mal, ich hab kein handy da
zum fotografieren, ihr müsst euch mal ein foto von der katze machen, wie sie da liegt,
chico jetzt nicht, die cat cam, sowas bräuchte man mal, gut das hätte ich auch noch hingekriegt,
der ist ja quasi in der luft gestanden, oh das war jetzt auch wieder prediktet, das habe
ich mir auch gefallen als prediktet, oh der war auch cool, das war nice, da hat er schon
aufgeräumt, die gegner, was, was ist mit den, Leute das sind wieder gegner die ihre tastatur
auf dem kopf haben, ich mein guckt euch das mal an, das ist doch nicht normal, wo gehts
los, ne, das ist der, die gegner, guckt euch das mal, richtig braindead gegner, oi, ich
mag die, guckt euch das mal an, sind die braindead, was, vor allem der typ, vor allem der typ,
guck mal, oh gucke mal, ein gegner, ja was könnte man da jetzt machen, ich gucke in
die richtung des gegners, aber ne, also auf die gegner schießen, das können wir jetzt
nicht machen, vielleicht war er afk, wahrscheinlich war er afk, aber die große prass ist, warum
steht er da und ist mitten in der runde afk, wenn er afk war, das ist ja noch, das ist
ja noch blöder, äh, dokter bob, weil, youtube, habe ich keine erklärung für, jawoll, bamm,
sehr gut, habt ihr, ich muss jetzt mal fragen, die leute, die viel battlefield 1 und, und
battlefield 5 spielen, ähm, ich hab ja beides so gut wie gar nicht gespielt, solche, solche
sachen hier, ich finde, sowas gab es, ziemlich oft in battlefield 3 und in battlefield 4
und auch in bed company 2, so, so coole, so coole ereignisse, die halt nicht gescriptet
waren und einfach passiert sind, weil es halt einfach sich dynamisch ergeben hat, und ich
hab den eindruck, wenn ich mir battlefield 5 videos angucke, solche ereignisse sind dort
recht selten, ich mein sowas ist einfach nice, ja, du, du snipest den chat und, ähm, der
chat fliegt dann vor dir runter und explodiert kurz bevor dir, kurz bevor du stirbst, das
war einfach, das ist einfach cool, ja, weil, weil es halt ungescriptet ist, ja, ja, ja,
ja, der hat farbenblib-virus an, wie die richtigen pros, so gehört sich das, der gegner
läuft einfach, die gegner sind alle ziemlich, ziemlich hol, ja, das war wieder schönes
video, ok was haben, was haben wir hier sonst noch schönes, schönes, bin ich eigentlich
Ich muss nachher unbedingt weiter Passive Exile Maps machen, aber nicht on stream.
Ja, Progress. Ich muss noch ein bisschen in der aktuellen League ein bisschen Progress machen.
Weil die geht ja nur noch einen halben Monat oder so.
Warum stellt man die Gegnerfarben auf grün? Weil man die Gegner besser sieht.
Ich mach keinen Passive Exile Stream. Passive Exile ist langweilig zu gucken.
Oh, die Katze will raus. Ich muss mal kurz die Tür aufmachen.
Anthem!
Passive Exile.
Passive Exile Stream finde ich...
Ich gucke selbst ab und zu welche, aber nur um mir anzugucken, was die Leute für Builds spielen und was es für Sachen gibt.
Also, das ist langweilig zu gucken.
Kannst du mal von BigMoney06 die Battlefield Top Plays Folge 100 gucken?
Äh, wenn du mir Link schickst?
Also wenn du Link hast, können wir mal reingucken.
Oder was? Big? Wie heißt der Typ? BigMoney?
Sagt mir Null.
BigMoney...
Was? 06?
Top Plays 100?
Äh, was davon? Das ist 6 Jahre alt!
Sicher?
Null.
Ah, nee.
Da muss man jetzt sagen, welches welches genau.
Max, meinst du, du kannst heute Abend oder morgen wieder einen Technik Stream machen?
Für den Q-Chat.
Ja, wenn es ein Thema gibt.
Wir haben ja gestern Abend schon Linux gestreamt.
Ähm...
Das erste...
14 Minuten!
Wow!
Okay, das ist wie alt.
Alter, okay, das war die beste Battlefield Zeit.
Okay, schauen wir mal. Gucken wir uns mal an.
Ein bisschen Battlefield kann nicht schaden.
Ein bisschen Battlefield.
Ähm...
Ich weiß nicht, ob an heute Abend, heute Abend eher, eher nicht.
Also, mal gucken, mal gucken.
Es muss ja immer ein passendes Thema geben.
XQC old.
Also, ich muss sagen, mein old emote finde ich besser.
Woop old.
Okay, die Grafik war damals reudig.
Die YouTube-Qualität.
Hat er mir weggespreit.
Zack. Bäm. Jawoll. Zack. In your face.
Next.
Bäm. Jawoll. So muss das sein.
Man sieht, damals haben genauso viele Bobs noch Battlefield gespielt.
Aber damals war es halt einfach mehr.
Guckt euch mal an, die Gegner sind auch komplett braindead wieder.
Komplett braindead.
Aber das ist ein echt geiler Clip.
Das ist ein echt geiler Clip.
Ja, das war echt gut.
Moin, Treblex.
A bit older finde ich gut im Kontext von einem Video, was vom 31. August 2013 ist.
Man sieht, die Gegner haben nicht wirklich was dazugelernt in den letzten 7 Jahren.
Dieses Feeling gab es nur in Battlefield 3 und beschränkt in Battlefield 4.
Beste.
Legehähne.
Die Legehähne am MKOM.
WTF.
Battlefield Physics.
Das war eine der Entscheidungen, die ich in Battlefield 3 bescheuert fand.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, welcher. War das Armored Kill?
Mit dem AC-130? War das Armored Kill?
Das hat den DLC nicht gut gemacht. Das AC-130 hat nicht gepasst.
Ist das Tala Market?
Ich kann die Maps gar nicht mehr genau.
Nee, das ist nicht Tala Market.
Doch, das ist doch Tala Market.
Die DLCs waren zum größten Teil gut, zum größten Teil.
Nicht alle, aber es waren richtig coole Sachen dabei.
Der letzte Mann, den ich getötet habe, war der Fakt, dass er keine Gesundheit mehr hatte.
Er könnte ihn irgendwo schießen und ihn sofort getötet haben.
Ansonsten geht er für das Old Cranium und rippt es einfach in einem Schuss.
Und wenn wir einen Sniper aus der langen Distanz nehmen,
wollen wir den Mann in der Nähe nehmen.
Wir sind weit gekommen, also im negativen Sinn, von Bad Company 2, Battlefield 3, Battlefield 4, zu aktuell Battlefield 5.
Aber ich gehe einfach davon aus, dass die meisten, die mit diesen Games was zu tun hatten, entweder gar nicht mehr da sind.
Man hört ja immer wieder, quasi gefühlt monatlich, dass irgendwelche Battlefield-Manager und Battlefield-Mitarbeiter und langjährige Battlefield-Blah-Leute weg sind.
Entweder sind sie weg, oder aber man lässt sie nicht mehr machen, was sie wollen.
Siebert, oh ja, Close Quarters, das war ein gutes DLC.
Ihr wisst, ich habe hauptsächlich weiterhin Rush gespielt und nicht viel Close Quarters, aber es war echt auch nice.
Das Commentary ist ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Weil Easykiller gerade Apex anspricht, ich habe den Eindruck, Apex ist gerade ein bisschen auf dem aufsteigenden Ast wieder.
Täuscht das, oder ist das echt so?
Bam, voll im Kopf.
Weil neue Season.
Aber das sind schon nice Shots bei.
Boah, der war cool.
Aber neue Season allein kann es doch nicht sein, oder?
Oder wie viele Season ist das jetzt in Apex?
Was ist ein cooler Feed?
Vier, ja aber bei den anderen war der Hype auch nicht so groß.
Jetzt habe ich das Gefühl, Apex ist wieder auf dem aufsteigenden Ast.
Gucken wir doch mal, was so die Twitch-Zahlen sagen.
Oder auch nicht, hier guck mal, das steht besser da, wie die letzten Monate.
Escape vom Tarkov, ja das verstehe ich auch nicht genau, warum das gerade so übelst abgeht, schon seit zwei Monaten oder so.
Apex ist relativ gut zur Zeit.
FIFA, seit wann ist FIFA bitte schön vorne bei...
Ok, das ist irgendeine E-Sport-Creamer.
Ansonsten ist FIFA nie vorne mit dabei.
Oder ich habe es schon selektiv ausgeplandet in meinem Hirn, kann auch sein.
Ja, schauen wir mal weiter.
Rust, ja es gibt Spiele, die gehen immer noch.
Boah, die Musik, das übertreibt man nicht.
Leute, was, aus welchem Game, von welcher Map ist der Soundtrack?
Was das? Game und und?
Also nicht weil Paraiso, also nicht weil Paraiso.
Passt, das Bad Company 2 schon mal richtig, welche Map?
Es gab in Bad Company 2 kein Navig.
Port Walters, Cold War, richtig.
Chet kennt sich aus.
Port Walters, Cold War, ja.
Oh, der war cool.
Und das war, das war Predicted.
Das war im Vergleich zu dem Kram, den wir vorhin, das war Predicted.
Und das hat halt funktioniert.
Wow, bam.
In your face, aber wortwörtlich.
Alter, das Commentary, das ist ja der Wahnsinn.
Da, da, da, da, da.
Also das voll emotionslos irgendwie.
Der F.
Sprech, sprech, sprech, sprech, sprech, sprech.
Ja, das ist ja auch eine gute Pose, das ist eine richtig gute Stelle hier.
Die Noobs, Alter, die Noobs kriegen auf den Sack.
Oh, null.
Die Gegner auch wieder, dass da aber keiner auf die Idee kommt, hier den Weg hier mal zu probieren.
probieren
Okay, da probiert's mal
Das merkwürdige ist, ich kann sogar die Waffensounds noch von Battlefield 3. Ich erkenne heute noch anhand der Sounds, welche Waffe
in Battlefield 3 verwendet wird.
Siehst du, es ist einfach ein absoluter Beste.
Tolle Dinge, Adrian. Tolle Dinge.
Turbobacon hier oben neben mir, auf dem Dämmer van Piek, mit dem kleinen Vogel, der nur hier um dieses Gebäude fliegt, auf Rush Mode, am Dämmer van Piek.
Das ging auch nur, wenn die Attacker oder Defender, je nachdem, wenn da keiner aufgepasst hat.
Der Heli hat hier gar nicht so viel Platz, also wenn da ein paar Leute mit Anti-Air am Start sind, ist der Ratzpaarz weg.
Turbobacon, ein deutscher Clip, echt? Gegner eliminiert, ja, ich seh's.
Es gab schon echt gute Heli-Piloten, ne?
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Das ist Pizzi. Das ist Pizzi, oder?
Ja, wenn nur ich das tun könnte. Ich geh in den Helikopter und krasche in den neuesten Polen, aber das ist toll, dieses Clip.
Das ist der Penz-Man.
Ich weiß nicht, ob viele von euch das Clip erinnern, aber es kommt von Episode 56 zurück.
Ja, dieses Clip ist ca. ein Jahr alt. Und ehrlich gesagt, es ist wahrscheinlich der beste Clip heute. Ich meine, es ist eine sehr starke Konkurrenz in dieser Linie heute, aber dieses Clip erhält den höchsten Pointstreak, ich denke, ich hab' wahrscheinlich schon mal gesehen, wie die Gegner explodieren, wenn sie auf einem kleinen Clip sitzen und die Leute spawnen, und er machte sie einfach über und über.
Aber zum Glück hat er einen Repair-Dudes dabei.
Oh, die kriegen auf den Sack. Guckt euch das mal an, wie die auf den Sack kriegen.
Ich meine, im Prinzip schießt er halt nur geradeaus, aber trotzdem kriegen die heftig auf den Sack.
Übrigens, fällt euch auf, das ist das, was ich an den letzten Streams gemein hatte. Ich glaube, das ist zu der Zeit, wo man Kanister-Shell und Main Turret nacheinander verwenden konnte.
Es ist ein Konkurrenz-Match oder so. Es sind kompetitive Teams. Beide Teams spielen eigentlich gegen einander.
Sie sind alle kompetitiv gespielt.
Und das Ding kann man zwischen.
Und es macht den Clip noch mehr toll. Ich meine, gerade jetzt, wir sind noch nicht halbwegs fertig und er hat über 2.300 Punkte in seiner aktuellen Streak.
Was geht mit dem gegnerischen Panzer ab? Der gegnerische Panzer hat ihm gerade eine Kanister-Shell gegen die Rüstung geschossen. Warum?
Was wird dem los?
Bepega-Tank. Ja, wahrscheinlich, um den Repair-Dude zu töten, aber das wird ja schwierig, wenn er dahinter steht mit der Kanister-Shell.
Das war ein übelster Streak. 4.318 Punkte.
Gazzatrini hier oben. Er fliegt gerade in der Lillebird. Und viele von euch können diesen Clip erinnern für seine tolle Kontrollmobilität.
Als er hier herumkommt, ist er wieder kaputt.
Ich glaube, das ist der Helikopter, aber er sagt, das ist der Helikopter. Ich nehme den D-Turr, als er ins Auto fliegt.
Und das ist die große Kontrolle, die er hier hat. Das ist der Helikopter hier. Das ist toll.
Das ist schon eine Map.
Was ist das für eine Map, Leute?
DLC, ja, aber was?
Mit den Mopeds, genau. Bandai Dazzat, ja, das kann sein.
Das kann sein.
Ihhh, das Scope. Was ist mit dem verkehrt?
Es sieht nicht immer so toll aus, wenn derjenige, der den Top-Plays macht, sagt, der Top-Plays ist der Beste rundherum.
Oh, schau mal, es ist ich. Mehrfach. Ich bin der Wiener. Es ist ich. Aber ihr votiert für den Wiener.
Das Scope? Warum?
Das war ein spezieller Episode. Und warum nicht einfach einen kleinen Clip von mir ausfüllen und das in den Mix werfen und sehen, ob ihr es überhaupt vergleichen könnt.
Ich weiß, die Map vorher, das ist die mit den Mopeds, wo sie diese Moped C4-Weitsprung-Geschichten hatten in Videos.
Das war nicht, das war auch nicht Firestorm davor.
Die anderen Clips, die heute hier auf den Top-Plays sind, persönlich denke ich, dass es viele Clips im heutigen Episode sind, die viel stärker sind als meine. Aber da seid ihr, ihr könnt es genießen, eine ziemlich tolle Clip zu sehen zu haben.
Dieser Clip hier ist wahrscheinlich einer meiner mehr erinnernden Momente, die ich je gespielt habe, in Battlefield 3.
Das ist ja selbst.
Das ist nicht mein höchstes Killstreak, den ich je gespielt habe, aber es war wahrscheinlich der tollste, den ich je gespielt habe, in diesem Spiel.
Die Map mit der Überflutung ist Battlefield 4 Flat Sound.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du es weißt oder nicht, aber wie viele von euch wissen, das Clip hier ist eigentlich von einem Say When-Episode, der im Januar begonnen ist.
Und wie gesagt, das ist einer der mehr erinnernden Momente, die ich je gespielt habe, in Battlefield 3.
Es fühlte sich so gut an, als ob man in einem der größten Storys, die wir in Battlefield 3 gespielt haben, gesehen haben.
Ich kann mich nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern, das klingt aber erstmal nicht verkehrt.
Jetzt muss ich mal was sagen, diese Map hier ist von dieser Nosha Canals TDM-Abschnitt, ist die Verkörperung dessen, was ich bei Modern Warfare Maps anmeckere, so nach dem Motto uninspiriertes Industriegebiet mit Containern.
Mit dem Unterschied, dass dieser Part hier von Nosha Canals, den sie für TDM genutzt haben, tatsächlich Laufwege und ordentliche Map-Aufteilung bietet, im Vergleich zu den meisten Modern Warfare Maps.
Obwohl sie genauso kacke aussieht.
Chris Downhenge, vier Monate, fünf Monate, danke schön, huge sub.
Huge, higher queues sub.
Huge spray.
Spray and pray.
Oh, da wird ein A-Aimt, da wird Hardcorkona-Aimt.
Ich schließe diesen Clip hier aus, durch ein großes Dankeschön an alle, die ihr Glauben und mir gebeten haben, eure Top-Plays auf wöchentlicher Basis zu erwerben.
Es sind jetzt über 2,5 Jahre, dass ich diese Top-Plays mache.
Es fühlt sich nicht so lange an, aber ich möchte euch bedanken für das Zuschauen.
SilencePain schreibt hier Battlefield 3 oder Bad Company 2 mit besserer Grafik, da machen die wieder Gewinn.
Ich glaube, ein Remake von den alten Games ist nicht der Weg, wie man da wieder ordentliche Battlefields machen könnte.
Ich glaube, das was sie wirklich machen müssten ist, ein Battlefield wiederbringen, was, ich sag mal, im Geiste von Battlefield ist.
Was zugänglich ist für alle, aber auch richtig viel Spieltiefe auf Dauer bietet, so wie es eben Battlefield 3, 4, Bad Company 2, eventuell, gut Hardline lassen wir mal außen vor.
Ja, also sagen wir mal, so wie die Battlefield 1, Battlefield 2, Battlefield 3, Battlefield 4, das ist eine richtig gute Basis gewesen.
Eine gute Kombination aus, es kann im Prinzip jeder spielen, es kann auch im Prinzip jeder mal geile Momente haben und gut außen,
aber es braucht halt die nötige Tiefe und das nötige Feeling und das Gesamtpaket, dass es die Spieler hält.
Zum Beispiel, erinnert euch vielleicht noch dran, was es für ein Riesenakt war, bis du Colonel 100 warst in Battlefield 3, das fand ich super, dass es so lang ging.
Das ist jetzt nichts, was das Gameplay besser gemacht hat, aber viele Leute, wenn du da einen Colonel 100 gesehen hast, war das nice.
Auch in Bad Company 2 hat es richtig lang gedauert.
Und auch gerade das coole und auch gerade an Battlefield 3, was ich halt persönlich auch richtig geil fand, wenn du einen Squad hattest aus 2, 3, 4 guten Leuten,
du konntest mit einem Squad aus 4 guten Leuten, und ich rede jetzt nicht von Heli oder Panzerbash, sondern Infanterie in your face Action,
wenn du einen guten Squad hattest, du konntest mit 4 Leuten, jetzt mal übertrieben gesagt 32 Leute bashen.
Und ich fand auch Squad Rush, ich bin immer noch der Meinung, wenn sie es wirklich machen wollen und ernst meinen,
könnt ihr euch noch an die Battlefield EA eSport Initiative erinnern?
Das haben sie bei Battlefield 1 schon großartig erzählt, so nach dem Motto, wir machen jetzt hier krassen eSport Shit,
und dann kamen ja nichts, nach einem Jahr kam Incursion, was sie dann wieder abgeschaltet haben,
dann sollte mit Battlefield 5 große eSport Geschichten gemacht werden, aber auch nicht.
Ich bin der Meinung, wenn sie es wirklich ernst meinen würden, dann würden sie sich erstmal einen ins Boot holen,
keine Ahnung, so was wie die ESL oder irgendwas, der ordentliche Turniere ausrichten kann, und dann müssten sie einen ordentlichen Squad Rush Modus machen.
Ich bin der Ansicht, Squad Rush oder 8 Mann Rush, wobei das fast schon zu viel ist, 8 Mann, du kriegst kein gescheites 8 Mann Team.
Die könnten Squad Rush machen mit 5 gegen 5 oder 6 gegen 6, 4 versus 4 ist vielleicht ein bisschen wenig,
oder ein richtig guter Competitive Squad Rush Modus ist glaube ich das Merkmal, was Battlefield eSport auszeichnen könnte, wenn man es ernst meint.
Ein guter Squad Rush Modus, das ist vor allem ein Modus, den kann man auch schön Observen,
das ist ja das, wo Overwatch immer noch dran krankt, den kann man schön Observen, man könnte es richtig schön quasi anhand der Attacker und Defender,
das es jeder machen muss, was er sich 5 mal attacken, 5 mal defenden, da könnte man so eine schöne Mischung basteln,
aus wie das Rainbow Six macht, so wie das CS macht, also man könnte wirklich sich aus der Erfahrung der letzten 10 Jahre,
die sich ergeben haben, was denn eben gut ankommt und was sich gut spielt, einen Squad Rush Modus basteln,
der nicht nur eSport tauglich ist, sondern der auch gut anzusehen ist und einfach nice wäre, aber ich glaube da sind die nicht mal in der Lage zu.
Ein neues Battlefield ist ja schon geplant, na ich hoffe ja, dass was an den Gerüchten dran ist, die schon seit 2 Jahren rumspucken,
dass sie einen Bad Company 3 machen, die Sache ist bloß die, es wird ja von DICE LA entwickelt, wenn die Gerüchte stimmen,
und ich hoffe halt, dass wenn es ein Bad Company 3 werden sollte, es nicht nur ein Bad Company 3 wird, was Bad Company 3 heißt,
sondern ein Bad Company 3, was halt den Namen Bad Company 3 verdient, weil man merkt, dass es der Nachfolger ist von Bad Company 1 und 2,
aber ich glaube die können das nicht mehr, ich glaube die haben es einfach verliert.
Hab gelesen, dass Bad Company 3 eingestampft wurde, kann auch sein.
Gucken wir mal Bad Company 3.
Bad Company 3 ist cancelled, ok.
Ok, warum?
Ok, im Prinzip, es sind Gerüchte, dass es kommen soll und es sind Gerüchte, dass es eingestellt wurde, also es sind alles Gerüchte.
Also die Community Version von Bad Company 2 kenne ich nicht, Silent Pain.
Ich kenne dieses Venise Unleashed für Battlefield 3, was keiner spielt.
Das war halt leider ein bisschen Totgeburt das Ganze.
So, was kann man hier noch so mieten?
Battlefield Top Plays haben wir schon geguckt, CS habe ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf, ehrlich gesagt.
Oh, GameStar, da kommen ein GameStar Video, können wir uns pro Tag schon mal geben.
Venise Unleashed gibt es nur, ja aber spielt keiner mehr.
Hier ein kleiner Rush Clip.
Ok.
Gucken wir uns, gucken wir uns, gucken wir uns an.
Locker.
Was geht denn da eigentlich gerade im Gang ab?
Ach, das sind die Claymore Tripwire oder was ist das?
Die sieht irgendwie ein bisschen fail aus.
Ist das die Tar?
Battlefield 4 Waffen muss ich immer ein bisschen länger überlegen.
Ja, steht da sogar oben, steht da sogar oben.
Sind sie weggesprayt?
Dankeschön!
DergoLive, zwei Monate.
Big Prane IQ Sub.
Du, du, du, du, du, du.
So muss das sein.
Ah, das ist PS4.
Ich hab mich schon gewundert, warum sich da so weich bewegt wird.
Aber klar, weil es PS4 ist.
PS4 mit Bewegungsunschärfe.
Und auch Legehennen machen, so gehört sich das.
Jetzt wäre ich gestorben.
Ich hab nämlich immer gerne, nachdem ich geklärt habe,
Legehennen gemacht hab und dann versuch, in Deckung zu gehen.
Was ist das für ein Potato Game?
Es ist PS4.
Wir sollten, wir sollten eine, eine, äh,
Woop Lores Max FPS Community Battlefield Top Plays Montage machen.
Aber ich sag mal, so sollten wir machen.
Das heißt, wenn ich das jetzt, wenn ich das jetzt sage,
dass wir das machen, dann, ähm, dann, dann, dann mach ich das eh nicht,
weil ihr kennt mich, wie zuverlässig ich bin mit Sachen, die, ne,
Sachen zu machen.
Was, wenn du mal blinde Gegner sehen willst, dann das hier.
Ich hab heute schon genug blinde Gegner gesehen.
Aber wir können, wir können ja trotzdem mal gucken.
Oh, gibt keinen Sound.
Kann man das, kann man die Quali ein bisschen höher machen?
Ist das Battlefield 1 oder ist das 5?
Ja gut, der, der ist wirklich, der ist wirklich blind.
Der ist wirklich blinder Typ.
Was, was geht mit den Gegnern wieder?
Ja, die sind, die sind, die sind wirklich blind.
Die sind echt huge, huge blind.
Ok, komm, wir gucken uns mal einen Gamestop wieder an.
Ohne diese Games würden wir jetzt ganz anders spielen.
Das ist wieder so ein typischer, äh, halber Clickbait Titel.
Ja, mal gucken.
Würden wir das, dass, äh, wir uns die Games da jetzt gleich erzählen,
warum das so ist.
Oh, Max Payne, beste, beste.
Eines der besten Spiele überhaupt.
Oh, Dragon Quest.
Oder Final Fantasy 1, von eins von beiden.
Die kann man, die kann man kaum auseinander halten.
Ich glaube aber, es ist Dragon, ich glaube es ist Dragon Quest.
Ich hab letztens ein Video drüber gesehen, wie sie diese Szene gemacht haben.
Oh, mit, mit ziemlich wenig CGI.
Auch wenn es nicht so aussieht, aber die Szene ist tatsächlich relativ wenig CGI.
Max Payne 3, äh, nicht 3, ich muss erzählen.
Max Payne 1, eines der besten Games für mich.
Leider sieht es halt heute aus wie Augenkrebs.
Ja, das ist das Tutorial Level.
Das ist alles das erste Tutorial Level, das haben die extra aufgenommen für das Video.
Ein wilder Patronentanz, das ist wieder so eine typische GameStar Formulierung.
Das ist genauso wie wenn sie bei Diablo 3 schreiben, die wilde Monster-Huts kommt in Fahrt oder sowas.
Das hast du schon mal in Fixfeld, sagt mir gar nichts.
Hab ich nie durchgespielt.
Erinnert mich ein bisschen, erinnert mich ein bisschen an die Assassin's Creed, äh, wie ist das, Assassin's Vision oder so.
...dass jederzeit klar ist, welcher Luftschacht begehbar, welche Wände spröde und welche Gegner gerade unvorsichtig sind.
Sowohl in den Schleich-Passagen als auch bei der Erkundung der Spielwelt ist Batman mit dem eingebauten Röntgenblick seinen Widersachern stets einen Schritt voraus.
Ähnliche Hilfsmittel gab es zwar schon in älteren Spielen, nach Arkham Asylum scheint aber lange kein Weg mehr daran vorbei zu führen.
Raider Reboots, Deus Ex, Human Revolution oder The Witcher 3 erlauben alle, das Spielwelt
durch andere Augen zu sehen, die wichtiges Farbliche vorheben und unwiss-
Der Switcher in 160p.
Häufig erspart man sich dadurch einen Blick auf die Minimap und kann einfach der roten
Markierung folgen.
Das senkt natürlich im Umkehrschluss den Anspruch und führt manchmal zu stumpfen Wimmelbild-Suchereien.
Für Entwickler ist der Scan-Modus aber eine einfache Methode, um Spieler in immer detaillierteren
Welten eine Orientierung und ein eindeutiges Ziel zu geben.
Gerade Open-World-Spiele strotzen häufig vor Aktivitäten und alle-
Bin ich eigentlich der Einzige, der die Tomb Raider Reboots nicht gespielt hat?
Schreit ein neuer Questgeber nach Hilfe, da kann so ein eingebauter Scanner für etwas
Ordnung im Chaos sorgen.
Jeder macht mal Fehler, wenn man aber gerade mit 200 Sachen um die Kurve heizt, kann das
ganz schön weh tun.
Ist auch schon alt.
Ja, ich hab sie sogar in meiner Steam-Bibliothek, aber ich hab sie noch nicht gespielt.
Ach ja, ich erinnere mich, das fanden damals die ganzen Rennsimulationsleute doof, dass
man zurückspulen kann.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Ja, ach da, ich wusste gar nicht, dass das daherkommt.
Juckt mich aber auch nicht, weil ich keine Rennspiele spiele.
Der Let's Play Noob 05.
Ja, mit dem Unterschied, mit dem Unterschied, dass Blizzard das seit 5 Jahren immer auf
die Reihe kriegt.
Es macht man nicht von tegen abort, kein Kam England hier developed, man hat doch eine
Master-Up und drei
Ohh, Warcraft I, Warcraft I Oh, sieht das schlecht aus, aus heutiger Sicht.
Oh, beste, beste! Alarmstufe ROT2, Leute!
Wobei, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist nicht Alarmstufe ROT2, das ist das erste Command & Conquer, oder?
Aber Alarmstufe ROT2, ich hab, glaub ich, kaum ein Strategiespiel so lang gespielt wie Alarmstufe ROT2.
Boah, das sieht, das sieht schon schlecht aus im Vergleich zu...
Boah!
Das sah halt schon auch sehr rudimentär aus, ja.
Ohne Warcraft hätten wir heute keine MOBAs.
Das glaub ich nicht, das glaub ich nicht.
Nur, eben Warcraft 3 hat sich halt angeboten.
Warcraft 3 war gut, Warcraft 3 war groß, hatte eine riesen Spielerbasis und hat halt einen guten Editor und alles.
Aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass das eigentliche Prinzip, also sprich, man nimmt ein Strategiespiel, reduziert quasi die ganzen Strategieelemente auf den Held,
dass das auch anderweitig sich entwickelt hätte, wenn es kein Warcraft 3 gegeben hätte.
Hier fehlt, genau, hier fehlt noch RTX On.
Läuft Dota eigentlich in Reforged?
Oder Master Chief.
Marzel, xMarzel, sechs Monate, Dankeschön, huge sub.
Oh, das Homeworld?
Nee, das ist nicht Homeworld, das ist Halo.
Ey, ohne Scheiß sah auf den ersten Blick, sah auf den ersten Blick aus wie Homeworld,
falls das jemand gespielt hat.
Aber nein, das ist eindeutig Halo.
Master Chief.
Ah, das stimmt, da ist was dran.
Im Prinzip, also was er damit sagen möchte ist, im Prinzip wurde Lebensregeneration für Konsolennoobs erfunden.
Das hätte man so übersetzt, was er sagt.
Ach Gott, zwei.
Telefonmast.
Oh, Resident Sleeper.
Genau, Morris, das machen wir.
Pac-Man, das ist mir zu oldschool.
Das habe ich nie verstanden, was daran gefällt.
Moment, will er uns jetzt erzählen, Pac-Man ist dafür verantwortlich, dass wir Zwischensequenzen haben?
Na, ich weiß ja nicht.
Magst du Tetris auch nicht?
Nee, um ehrlich zu sein, mag ich Tetris auch nicht.
Ich habe zwar Tetris, die Gameboy-Originalversion habe ich zwar damals gespielt, aber war halt sinnloses Minigame im Endeffekt.
Generell finde ich gab es wenig, am Anfang vor allem richtig wenig gute Gameboy-Spiele.
Das Gameboy-Zelda war ziemlich gut, Mario World auf dem Gameboy war rotz, Tetris war auch nichts gut, es gab viel Crap auf dem Gameboy.
Boy!
Der Job von Kratos ist ja prinzipiell krimmig gucken.
Ich glaube, die haben für Kratos einen Motion-Capturing-Typ, der hat überall Motion-Capturing außer im Gesicht.
Hier guck, guck, der hat überall plus nicht im Gesicht, weil Kratos braucht keine Gesichtsausdruck.
Kratos muss immer krimmig gucken.
Sag mal, Leute, der Typ, ist das der aus Stargate?
Der sieht voll aus wie der Typ aus Stargate.
Hören Sie den hier auch? Ich habe keine Ahnung wie der Typ hieß in Stargate.
Der, der sieht, der sieht.
Ja, ne?
Das Gesicht wie mit der Kamera getrackt.
Ja, man sieht schon, dass Kratos halt nicht viele, der bewegt sein Gesicht ja auch nicht.
Ohje.
Zur Hölle ja!
Also Gears of War denke ich als erstes an die schlechte deutsche Übersetzung.
Zur Hölle ja! In dein Gesicht!
Als Originalquote aus der deutschen Gears of War Übersetzung.
Ein Druck auf die dazugehörige Taste und der Charakter beginnt eine symbiotische Beziehung mit...
Zur Hölle ja! In dein Gesicht!
Was erzählen die in Gears 1 in Deutsch?
Das war das Spiel, wo ich gelernt habe mit dem Controller zu spielen wieder.
Als ich für die Xbox gekauft habe, also die 360, habe ich mit dem Friseur zusammen das Spiel dreimal durchgespielt.
Halt normaler Schwierigkeitsgrad schwer und sehr schwer und falls es Ultra gab, dann haben wir es viermal durchgespielt.
Und ich muss euch sagen, gerade die Szene in Gears of War, wo das Team aufgesplittet war, also sprich, wo man Koop gespielt hat, aber nicht zusammen in der Mission war, sondern einer den Teil gespielt und ein anderer den Teil gespielt hat, die waren richtig schwer.
Gears of War 1 ist immer noch das beste.
Das war das Spiel, wo ich gelernt habe, was ich gelernt habe, was ich gelernt habe, was ich gelernt habe.
Der Typ hat aber komische Nackenmuskeln, oder? Guckt euch das mal an.
Das könnte gut sein, sagt Gears, ja, das erste Gears haben wir noch aus England bestellt.
Take cover, take aim, take over. Kill Switch ist allerdings kein besonders großer Verkaufshit, zeigt aber, wie ein Deckungsshooter aussehen kann. Lead Designer Chris Isaki wird nach der Veröffentlichung von Kill Switch sogar für die Entwicklung von Gears of War engagiert.
Beim zweiten Anlauf wird die Mechanik dann auch prägend für eine ganze Spielegeneration.
Das Ego-Shooter-Genre hat viele Mütter und Väter.
Gäbe ich Ihnen recht, Quake. Ja, das kann ich so unterschreiben Quake. Nicht Doom, sondern Quake ist das Spiel, was für die moderne FPS-Steuerung maßgebend war.
Doom war ja quasi noch, man kann es nicht 2D nennen, Doom war halt noch flach, es gab kein oben und unten in dem Sinn. Quake ist die Grundlage jeder modernen FPS-Steuerung.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass sie gleich noch Quake zeigen werden.
Quake, gäbe ich Ihnen voll und ganz recht. Quake, ja.
Da muss ich Ihnen unangeschränkt recht geben.
Quake heute, Quake kannst du mit dem RTX-Mod spielen.
Also grafisch ist es, ich finde Quake 1, gerade Quake 1, es ist von vielen 3D-Spielen ganz gut gealtert, aber das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, weil es halt darauf ausgelegt war pixellig auszusehen.
Es ist ganz okay gealtert, aber es sieht halt schon ziemlich augenkrebsmäßig aus.
Zu Mecha für Competitive Hardcore-Zocker, das ist auch wieder so eine Gamestar-Formulierung.
Laufanimationen waren overrated.
Ja, da ist doch Dragon Quest, was wir am Anfang gesehen haben.
Also man darf jetzt nicht denken, dass im Hintergrund fährt das Soundtrack vom ersten Dragon Quest.
Ja, das gab es ja damals auch.
Da haben sie aber nicht unrecht.
Wir waren nicht ganz bewusst, dass Dragon Quest das erste war.
Aber Chrono ist eines der besten Spiele überhaupt.
Da gab es vor zwei Wochen einen neuen Speedrun-Weltrekord.
Ich habe noch nicht geguckt, aber wie die Leute dieses Game mittlerweile spielen ist der Wahnsinn.
Das war dieses Event mit dem Preisgeld.
Die Levels sahen da schon relativ blockig und zusammengeschustert aus.
Aber das Movement war das, was da aufgewacht hat.
Und die Kamerasteuerung war auch gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Wenn man mit der Steuerung ein bisschen herumext...
Ja, Twitch ist RIP.
Jetzt wieder?
Geht wieder?
Also ich habe nichts gemacht, ich habe einfach nur gewartet.
Ich refresche mal mein Vorschau.
Wie gesagt, das liegt nicht an mir, ich kann daran nichts ändern.
Das ist Twitch.
Ja.
Typische Informatik, aber die anderen schon.
In dem Fall ist es offensichtlich, dass ich dafür nichts kann.
Es gibt noch ein paar Videos, die ich schon mache, die ich jetzt auch machen will.
Die haben auch Leute, die ordentlich Videos sprechen können.
Früher war das sehr gezwungen.
Ihr müsst euch mal GameStar Videos von 2014 oder 2015 anhören.
Das war sehr anstrengend und cringe teilweise zuzuhören.
Obwohl ich ihn am Anfang nicht mochte, sind die Videos von Maurice, die gucke ich mir auch gerne an.
Die habe ich am Anfang überhaupt nicht gerne geguckt.
Mittlerweile gucke ich die am liebsten.
Ich finde die nicht schlecht, man kann die sich echt geben.
Warum ist RTL eigentlich so schlecht?
Ich glaube die Antwort ist relativ einfach, weil sie es gut verkauft.
Was sind das für komische Videoempfehlungen?
Tomatenkonserven, in welcher Dose steckt gute Ware?
Das habe ich mich auch schon immer gefragt.
Warum soll ich mir Tomatenkonserven angucken?
Call of Duty Modern Warfare vs. Battlefield 4.
Was? Haben die abgeguckt oder was?
Wim vs. Emacs, das Fuzz mache ich heute nicht auf.
Das merke ich mir für nächstes Mal.
Wir haben schon so viel Battlefield geguckt heute.
How to survive 4 weeks mit 50 Euro.
Ich habe einen Tipp für denjenigen.
Einfach gucken, dass man in diesen 4 Wochen mehr Geld kriegt.
Je nachdem was man sich so kauft, kommt man mit 50 Euro wahrscheinlich 4 Wochen über aus.
Man kauft nur die günstigsten Sachen und die die viel Kalorien haben und satt machen.
Mal gucken, ob das Video etwas taugt.
Nudeln und Ketchup sind billig und man kann es essen.
Reis, Brot, Haferflocken, Reis, Dosen, Tomaten.
Das erste was mir in den Kopf kommt wäre Nudeln und Ketchup.
Und es ist billig.
Sondern italienisch ist es nicht.
Was passiert gerade?
Der verarscht russischen Akzent gerade oder geht das ganze Video so?
Die sind alle so.
Was passiert da gerade?
Ist das seine Oma?
Ich bin russisch nicht so fett.
Was passiert da gerade?
Was gucken wir uns da gerade an?
Okay, der ist saugroß, ich hab noch nicht ein Video von ihm geguckt.
Für 50 Euro kann ich 5 mal Mittagessen gehen in Frankfurt und das wird schon knapp.
Süße und salzige Cornflakes, äh nicht Cornflakes, Haferflocken.
Das schmeckt doch bestimmt eklig.
Ich weiß nicht ob das gut schmeckt.
Es hat ein bisschen was von how to basic, ja stimmt, aber nicht ganz so abgedreht.
Ja gut, es sind Macaroni mit Käse und Eiern drin, das kann man essen, aber Leute überlegt euch mal,
du isst ihr Esses jeden Tag für vier Wochen, naaah.
Da fehlt Wodka, kommt bestimmt noch.
Jetzt weiß ich auch warum er so eine riesenfette Wurst gekauft hat, weil überall kommt die Wurst rein.
Ouh!
Da wird die, die werden nicht geschält. Das wäre Verschwendung, hä?
Ist das, ist das Pomfret light oder was kommt da jetzt raus?
Es hat, es hat ein bisschen was von how to basic. Also wie das Zeug da rumklatscht.
Da kommt jetzt noch ein Ei dabei, das war klar.
Okay, das kann man wahrscheinlich echt essen.
Wenn Naxo, das gibt es ja leider nicht mehr.
Was er für eine Sauerei hinterlässt.
Gibt das halt fertig jetzt.
Das sieht auch wirklich aus.
Was?
Ja, das muss ich jetzt sagen.
Das war mal hier ein High IQ Video.
Also ich komme in Frankfurt mit 50 Euro kann ich vier bis fünfmal Mittag essen, das war's.
Hast du die Top 25 Spiele der letzten zehn Jahre von Game Two schon gesehen? Nee? Leute, ich muss aufs Klo.
Ich glaube wir müssen Stream jetzt ausmachen. Ich muss aufs Klo und ich habe Hunger.
Ja, ich mache Schluss. Wir sehen uns. Danke, dass ihr alle dabei wart für die ganzen Subs.
Und für alle, an alle die zugeschaut haben. Morgen wieder, morgen Abend please. Morgen Abend spielen wir vielleicht oder vielleicht sogar heute Abend mal gucken.
Müssen wir noch Titanfall die Kampagne fertig spielen, das dauert noch so drei, vier Stunden.
Ich musste auch Subtitel mitlesen. Ja, geht nicht anders.
Okay Leute, wir sehen uns. Macht's gut. Bis dann.